good morning believe nation today's
messages find your inspiration over to
you Lady gaga and my own artists have my
own vision
I suppose that there's one
interpretation of the female to sing a
love song and look pretty and just you
know I guess do what everyone thinks you
should do but it's just not what
inspires me and I'm inspired not just by
you know what I see in terms of the
future of music or tech or or fashion I
see also my fans and I think about what
they want to experience and they love to
feel out of touch with reality for a
moment so it might feel shocking maybe
but I really think it's just this sort
of surreal fantasy that I take pleasure
in creating for you one of the things
that's most important to have as an
entrepreneur is something that
differentiates you I think too many
people who start a business there's the
only exact same thing as everybody else
whether it's a product or service and
there's no point of differentiation if I
can't tell what's different between you
and somebody else so while we're gonna
go with you
right I'm just gonna beat you down on
price because you haven't done your job
in communicating what's different and I
think if you really look at a lot of
products and companies there isn't
actually that much that is different and
that's because the people behind it
didn't find their inspiration and
finding your inspiration is scary and it
leads you off on paths that don't make
sense and because they don't make sense
then you don't do it because you're
looking for an immediate return on
investment because you can't justify the
time to go out and pursue something that
you're kind of curious about but it's
important because that's where the gold
is that's where the food is that's where
the magic happens it's by chasing
something that you are personally
excited by that makes you come alive
that even if it doesn't make sense yet
you have to have the confidence and
faith and believe that it is gonna work
out at some point if you're thinking
about doing something that's been on
your list or a long Tomica I really want
to do this just go out and start find a
small way to start and see if it makes
you come alive see if it's the thing
that you thought it would be and if not
to move on to something else stop just
making lists and listing
list of things that are on your bucket
list one day to do and actually go out
and start doing so the question today
today is how do you find your
inspiration I'm really curious to find
out leave it in the comments below I'm
gonna join a discussion thank you so
much for watching and have an amazing
day continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events pressing